okay
okay i think it's a good time to get
started um
hi everyone to this pi data cambridge
our 30-second meet up in june 2021
and of course we are still online uh
and and first of all i invite everyone
in the
in the webinar to please introduce
yourself in the chat if you feel
comfortable
just tell us where your base where you
work
it's really interesting to see and
connect with other people
and we're doing this online now we used
to do it in person
so it's nice to uh to to kind of chat
and see where people are coming for a
meetup great so the agenda for today is
this introduction talk as
as as i'm going through it we'll have
our our big talk which is the spotlight
on emma opps
uh by sam richardson we'll have us a
small break and then we'll have the
lightning talks from uh
from chacho from uh kate taylor and
only and then we'll wrap it up
as a note and it's already recording
this this meetup is being recorded
and we'll post it on youtube afterwards
uh so who who who we are is essentially
we're the local meetup chapter for
cambridge
uk uh we we we started in november 2008
and we we had one monthly meet-ups every
wednesday of the last month and we used
to have them
at the raspberry pi headquarters
and this is organized by by me
uh joris leandro and oli
and just as a note that we are that we
are all volunteers so this is what we do
in our spare time and and we we like
kind of
like to promote this community
so just a bit more information about
what pay data pi data is essentially an
educational program of noon focus which
is which promotes open code because that
means better science
new focus is essentially one of our
sponsors because they help us
with the meetup setup with the zoom
account so essentially they're
financially helping
this this meetup and and as you may know
new focus support supports a lot of open
source projects in the scientific
data stack so a lot of the a lot of the
libraries that you may use like pandas
numpy
and it's a really really important place
i do ask you to donate
since they are a charity i do ask you to
donate to them you
if you use those libraries it helps to
help support
meetups like the one we have here
uh we do have a color conduct uh and
this and essentially
the the gist of it is that you this is
this is a professional environment so
you have to behave professionally
we do have also a code of conduct
response team for any
any code of conduct issues that you
would like to report so that's all the
organizers that i started before
and someone independent to the
organizers which is leone
uh who is a uh is independent and you
can if you don't feel comfortable
approaching the organizers
uh okay we also have to thank our
sponsors
uh which is arm fetch ai uh
raspberry pi and as i mentioned before
noon focus
they essentially help us organize this
when we used to be in person they would
help us with pizza
drinks and for for some of the speakers
to travel
in this case uh they're helping us with
the meat of
meet-up fees and zoom licenses so so
please
uh please if you do contact any of these
sponsors please let them know that that
you found about them
about them in pi data cambridge
uh so from our raspberry pi they're
still
i believe they're still doing their
weekly live streams
so you can check out their website about
what you can do about
making making stuff at home so please do
contact them or go to their website
uh fetch ai is also
uh supporting us and you can see a lot
of the interesting things that fetch ai
is working on uh and also more
importantly if you're interested in
joining them
uh they have a lot of positions open uh
at the moment so please do contact them
and mention us if
you found it interesting uh if you want
to help us you know
support us so that we can keep our
sponsors
and for arm although we don't have any
specific positions relevant for pi data
cambridge that i know of
i'm i work at arm please do visit our
careers website there are a lot of
positions open
uh so in a lot of different locations
actually since a lot of people
in youtube might be watching us from all
over the world
so please do check out if there's
anything interesting for you
finally uh how to contact us we're
always looking for speakers we're also
looking always looking for sponsors and
we can we can see what level of
sponsorship we
we can we can we can have at the moment
and also that our recordings are all in
the pi data tv youtube
and this and you can contact us in
twitter or on our email
pidatacambridge gmail.com
and that's it so if you do want to speak
or you're interested in what we're doing
please do email us
and contact us okay so that's it
uh so we'll start with our first speaker
which is sam and i'll let him share his
screen
stop showing
all right
sorry one sec i think that should be
fine
again okay
great is that sharing uh no can you see
it should be sort of on a
powerpoint uh yes it is sharing
one last thing i wanted to say we do
have a q a button
so please do use it to add your
questions and i
will i'll ask them um at the end of this
of the talk
so please do use the q a box there
yeah so up on to you sam
great thanks uh hi so hi everyone i'm
sam richardson
and today i'm going to be talking about
machine learning operations or
ml ops
so this is a quick rundown of the talk
so first i'll talk about
why envelopes is important and what it
is and next i'll cover the two main
areas
which are model training and models
serving and finally leave with a few
short conclusions
so again my name is sam richardson i
work as a data scientist at gft
i'm based in the cambridge ai lab and we
work in from
we're based in the wework in cambridge
um so this has been a recently created
team to develop new propositions
thought leadership and undertake data
science consulting projects for industry
we work with a wide range of different
industries so automobile manufacturing
and insurance
some of the ones we worked with and
prior to this i worked as a
startup in aviation field and my
background's in material science
so i said i work in gft's cambridge team
and we have focused on data science and
machine learning
and this is a quick overview of
different team members we work very
closely with a lot of collaboration
and all the team members have
contributed to the work i'll discuss
today
so as i said ml ops is short for machine
learning operations and it's the
practice of using
tools infrastructure and workflows to
productionize machine learning systems
so why is this important i'll start with
a personal story about when i first came
into contact with putting mr systems
into production
so my previous job i worked as a data
scientist at this startup and we
participated in this four-week
accelerator program
so this was with a big industrial
partner and it went really well
so they provided some data from the
systems we cleaned it up produced some
models and they had really good
performance
so everyone was happy with this it was
uh sort of a nice result
and this was great until they asked us
to run a live trial on real data for six
months
um so this was a challenge as the system
we had was sort of
based on sort of several jupiter
notebooks it really wasn't set up to run
in this way
so we had a lot of work following this
to get the system running into a
framework where
we could ingest regular batches of data
so there are
four key benefits really for
implementing good ml ops practice that
would have really helped a lot after
this accelerator program
so the first major advantage you get is
uh with improving your ability to
collaborate with others so if you have a
shared experiment framework
it means you're sort of aligned on
methodology and allows for much simpler
collaboration
reproducibility of your work's the
second one so this is incredibly
important for
any type of sciences you you can't
really build upon and develop what
you're doing without it
so the third is around scale so
having good infrastructure and practices
is becomes really important as the scale
becomes larger so
things that could be say a quick manual
fix or
sort of a simple job at small scales
become impossible to deal with as the
data becomes larger
and the ingest velocity increases and
then the final points around security
so by having these practices in place
you get oversight and governance of your
data and models
and this is sort of crucial for securing
the system and making sure
say sensitive data isn't seen by the
wrong person
um so this is really important for a lot
of systems
so mrs infrastructure tools and
workflows for production ml
um this diagram detailed sort of a
typical say machine learning system
in very basic terms so say from right to
left data is collected
prepared a machine learning model is
trained and then the model will be
deployed to production
and evaluated as predictions are made
and we'd group this process into two
main components when designing the
infrastructure
so there'd be model training and then
model serving
and then the complication of managing
these components
is that the output of a machine learning
system is a function of
the data ingested at the start as well
as the code
so you can control the code that you
write and that can be controlled for
but you can't control say the data
coming into a live system so easily
um so you get sort of extra
complications and you need sort of extra
logging
and tracking um
so here's um sort of an
example infrastructure um that we would
have set up to use google cloud a lot
this is example say a set of tools for
google cloud
um and the infrastructure requirements
for implementing say a proper framework
can be complex
um so say this our infrastructure has
different components say for user
interface
model serving model training and then
security and operations
so there's kind of two things we use to
kind of help us with dealing with a lot
of this infrastructure
so the first is we make use of a lot of
managed cloud services
which reduces the maintenance burning
for us and any clients we work with
and there are huge amount of different
managed cloud services from these
different cloud vendors that can sort of
reduce
it management needs and then the second
one
is around infrastructure and code so
this allows us to say manage the setup
and tear down
all these components in a reliable
fashion and we
use an open source tool for this called
terraform um so this
really you represent all of your
infrastructure as code
and you can say version it it would
allow a small team to kind of quickly
set up and maintain
complex and powerful infrastructure um
the kind of thing you'd need for
supporting a production
machine learning system um so that's
kind of the overview of what it is
and sort of why it's important um so now
i'll talk a bit about the model training
part of the piece so model training is
generally performed in a data pipeline
so this could be batch or streaming data
for
and then for model training the key
elements to look for
are say the pipelines themselves um data
testing
and then sort of tracking of metadata
and artifacts that are produced from the
the pipeline
so a good pipeline framework will allow
a team to say manage and schedule the
work to be performed
so here you can see we start with raw
data
prepare the data test the data we end up
with model ready data
so sort of cleaned up then we can fit a
model and we would output say
a trained model object so
at each stage of the process um there's
a huge amount of this metadata to
capture
um for in terms of reproducibility and
governance
so i've given some details of sort of
some of the pieces of information you
might be looking to
keep at each stage and what we typically
do is have say structured data in a
metadata store and then
unstructured things like a model object
could go in a
artifact store so for each of these sort
of key elements i'll go through a bit
more detail
and provide some examples of the tools
we typically use in the team
so uh pipeline frameworks are
sort of really nice for managing data
pipelines typically the frameworks are
based on dags
which is a directed acyclic graph
so this means uh the work performed is
directed
in that it goes from a to b and it does
not cycle
so this is an example picture of a dag
you can see
it goes from run this first to join uh
from a to b
it doesn't cycle but within these two
constraints you can have say a lot of
different complex logic
so here you're getting say a lot of
different branching going on
um airflow is a popular option it's one
we use sort of commonly within our team
so it has a lot of really great features
including sort of nice ui for managing
pipelines and jobs
and a scheduler for triggering jobs and
can do things like send you
email alerts if there are any issues and
because
it's sort of one of the most commonly
used tools it has a really large
community
good documentation and a wide range of
different integrations
and then also quite importantly uh sort
of for our team it has a lot of managed
service implementation so
on all major cloud platforms so this
sort of simplifies setup and management
if you're
trying to set up something and you don't
have a huge a large team to say maintain
it
so in terms of pipeline frameworks
recently there's been a huge amount of
development in these tools
um over the last few years and they all
sort of approach the challenge slightly
differently
um so two ones i think are very
interesting is kedro is a particularly
nice tool
um so this can be used in conjunction
with airflow
and is used specifically around sort of
authoring the actual pipeline work
itself
and it kind of allows you to maintain
really nice development standards when
you're sort of
creating a data science workflow um
and cube flows very nice as well if
you're sort of
running on kubernetes
so next i'll talk about data testing um
and as i said sort of before
the output of a machine learning system
is a function of the code that describes
the pipeline
um and sort of more importantly is in
terms of it's the data that goes
in so that's the part that can vary a
lot
so the code you can test regularly with
unit tests and system tests
but it's also very important to perform
data tests as well as new data comes
into the systems
so uh one of the big assumptions you
have when you train a machine learning
model is that
the sample of training data you train
the model on is representative of
this wider population that will come
through the data during production
so it's important to make sure that as
new data comes in it matches the
expectations you have about the data
there's out of distribution data that
can sort of quite quickly turn the best
models into
random number generators um so this is a
fun
example from that was published by open
ai
so this is a model say that they've
trained to recognize visual
features but also text as well
so say it works well in the first
picture of the apple but if you had
pictures of fruit with
labels on them um it would get quickly
confused so say
putting a piece of paper with ipod on it
now makes it classify as an ipod
um this kind of shows it's important to
understand
what data is coming into your system and
you want to aim for the data that's fed
into the model during production matches
the assumptions you make
during training so generally the best
idea is to say when you set up your
system
you can explicitly write your
assumptions about the data
and use these as tests during the
pipeline runs um so this is kind of
the the method that's used by great
expectations so this is an open source
tool that we use a lot
um so you can use this tool to test data
against a list of expectations
and output the results as um
structured json files if you want to do
sort of machine automation
or human interpretable html reports
and then finally in terms of model
training
to make the work undertaken by the
pipeline accountable and reproducible
it's important to have proper logging
and the aim is to create
in the aim sorry for creating a
reproducible pipeline is to record
enough information so
you could trace a pipeline run back to
the input or sort of set of environments
that you set it off with
or if you have a result you can then
produce that identical result again um
and so pipelines output structured and
unstructured data will really be tracked
um we typically use a metadata store for
structured
and an artifact store of unstructured
data so ml
flow is an open source tool which can be
used for managing both of these
repositories
um it has a really nice ui that allows
you to
explore the track data and a really
flexible tracking api that's quite
simple to just add into your code
and start adding tracking hooks
throughout um the work you're writing
the other nice thing about it is it's
very modular and you can use different
storage backends for the metadata in the
artifacts
so we work a lot in google cloud and you
can use say a managed sql instance
for your structured data and then google
cloud storage for your
object data um but there's sort of
tie-ins with say
s3 for aws or the azure blob store if
you're in
azure so now i'll do a quick demo of
some of these components just kind of
give you an idea how they look
um so this would be a quick show of
different components running on google
cloud platform
um and i'll show airflow with some data
pipelines
some metadata and artifacts in ml flow
and
data testing with great expectations uh
right so i'll switch over my screen now
so hopefully everyone should be able to
see a web browser
um so this is the airflow interface
um on the interfaces is kind of the main
panel you get you get sort of your lists
of different
jobs um so these are all different dags
that describe sort of the
the tasks um you get some management
info in terms of owner
how many runs have been successful or
failed recently information about
the schedule around the last run and
sort of recent
tasks and then say you can go on a
particular task
so this is kind of a sort of developed
system we have running
um so this is one task for doing say an
etl job
um and within that dag you're getting
say different views
oops
right let's go to the different one so
within the task you get different views
and you can kind of track
um where the tasks are i think i might
have lost connection to my vm
which are in the talk start and you can
also do things like
um look at say the code that's produced
and set up different admin controls etc
so next i'll go on ml flow
so this is what we use for say tracking
different pipeline information and
tracking our experimental runs
um so here everything's split into
experiments
um so often we use say like a different
experiment for say
a different model training and also
often
keep an experiment running to track say
etl processes as well so you can see
what say version of the data is running
in or when
the date you've sort of ingested your
different data streams um so you get
sort of all your different
runs um you can look at different model
packages that have been
used different parameters you've logged
different metrics you've recorded
um so say if you go on a particular
model run
this is one model being trained you can
see all different parameters
metrics and then you also get
unstructured objects attached to this
run as well so you get
information about the model the model
object itself
it also has a model repository
let's reconnect
it's the only problem with doing live
so it also does have a model repository
um
so this would allow you to look at
different versions of the models
um and you can tie back and the thing
that's really nice that i was going to
show
now was um you can go for say a
particular model
and trace it back to the original source
run that it came from
so this is where you start to tie the
picture together and go
from the the models in your repository
that are ready to put in production
and train them back to that original run
where they came from
um and last i'll just go on great
expectations
so um this is the tool we use for data
testing um
and it has kind of two sort of main
modes the first thing you can do is look
at profiling your data sets
so you might do this when a new dataset
comes in this is very similar to pandas
profiling if anyone's used that
and you get kind of an overview of some
of your data in terms of the main
uh data set and then the different
parameters
distribution sort of etc um so then when
you've got your data and you understand
what's going on
and you've sort of created expectations
around what you expect you can write
these
explicitly as a set of expectations
so this is just a set of tests and they
they represent this as a json file
but they have sort of a couple different
apis for authoring these if you don't
want to write it sort of as raw json
and when you're set up and running you
can do regular tests so these are say
regular tests going into our storage
system
and then you get reports out as your
data test is performed so
this can output here's a adjacent if you
want to automate the next stage your
pipeline or
if you want a human in the loop type
system you can output these as html
reports and see
whether your tests are successfully
being completed
so this is a very simple kind of example
type test
i have six expectations on my data you
can see that say
this field is required it's not null and
the values are
belonging to the set i expect um but
it's this kind of thing you can set up
and sort of build up your expectations
and then avoid say issues of say strange
data being pulled into your system
um right so that's kind of everything i
want to talk about in terms of a quick
overview of different tools
used for model training so
now we have say our machine trained
machine learning model
and we're ready to deploy the model to
production
so the best approach here is to deploy
the model as an api
so this is decoupled from the
application logic um
and this simplifies the development and
allow those developing the model
to work independently of the application
code
so data can be processed by the model
online
say for a synchro synchronous low
latency response or
offline for an asynchronous batch
prediction
um and the general flow you can have
would be your model is taken from your
model repository
it's set up in your service and then
application client can request
predictions um and then the model can
supply the predictions and then
push the uh logging information to some
sort of
model logs um
so in terms of infrastructure as before
we try to use managed services for these
wherever we can
um and for serving this gives a lot of
advantages so this is things like auto
scaling
authentication and sort of simple
management tools
so generally the deployment tools are
around deploying a
docker container or deploying a model
object itself
and generally we found that container
deployment has been more flexible for
our needs so
um there's often restrictions in what
model libraries you can use with the
model deployment options
um and it's sometimes trickier to sort
of hook on different elements
so there are sort of options for
container or model deployment on
sort of all the major clouds so gcp has
ai platform or vertex ai for doing
managed model deployment
and then cloud run for doing managed
container deployment
um and this is kind of an example
workflow in gcp
so you would have the model deployed so
it's taken from mlflow
um you'd have the can the image built in
cloud build which is a cicd
tool for just building docker images you
can store that image in a repository
and then deploy it as your model service
so this would run
as a managed service in cloud run and
results can be requested from the user
as through this rest api
and then any logging information as the
models run can be pushed to cloud
logging
so you can track what's going on and
then also we often hook it up to
an in-memory memory base like uh redis
so this is a managed version of redis
if we have say additional information
that's added in during the training so
things like say if there was weather
information
and this would allow us just to sort of
independently hydrate this service
without having to redeploy the whole
model
um
so i'll try and do a quick demo
hopefully
let's see if it's still running when we
try and get onto it
so in this one we're going to be looking
at some model training serving
components
um so this will be compute running in
google cloud run
and then logging running in google cloud
logging and then i've used a sync to
push that information into google
bigquery sort of for easier analysis and
uh
visualization
right so we should be back on the
web browser so this is on google cloud
platform
uh so this is the cloud run interface um
and you get on the first instance you
get kind of a list of your different
services
um so these are all different apis that
are running
and the tick means that it is sort of up
and running ready to go you get
information about how many requests
you're getting recently
um what region they're running in
um sort of etc and then say who deployed
them when they were deployed
you can look at a particular service so
this is one of our apis we set up
you get different metrics so this is
kind of some of the management tools i
was talking about
you can see say how many requests counts
you get information about billable times
you can understand the cost you're
running
um at the moment this is a slightly
older api so
um there isn't any data but it just sort
of populate all these fields
automatically
you can start doing different revisions
and do kind of continuous deployment
type
uh running then you also get different
logs as well
um and you can choose to sort of which
information from that api
call you want to run out as a log
and then what i've done here is because
we were using this information to
populate
a dashboard i've put the information to
google bigquery
so this is just google's sort of data
warehouse solution
and you can see the data set here so um
this is the logging information you can
see things like what project it's from
what's my service name and then you get
sort of some of the more information
interesting information so you get the
model version so this corresponds to
the model version in our model
repository that's managed by ml flow
you get say the model name you get the
response that the model gave on this
particular
instance you get the information
provided by
the the user who called the api
um so this is where you can kind of see
you're getting that joined up picture
where you could go
here is my model it is this model
version i can track it back to my
repository
and then from my repository i can see
the source run that uh
the model was trained from and you see
exactly what the environment that the
model was trained from
um so this is kind of how you get to the
point where you can if you were to get
to it at the point where someone comes
to you
and says that there's an issue and the
model is giving strange results um it's
caused this sort of strange action
you could go look at your log see what
the result was
and track it back to sort of the
original source of
uh how the model was trained and what
went into the model in the first place
so this kind of gives you the sort of
full governance picture um
in terms of your pipeline uh
race so that's kind of everything in
terms of model serving and that sort of
completes my very quick
overview of uh these different system
components
uh so in conclusions um i'd say
hopefully this talk is showing that
mlops is kind of really key to
putting machine learning into production
and
really it gives you sort of aid with
collaboration
reproducibility and working at scale and
security
the next thing is to keep in mind is
that the machine learning system is a
function of the data and the code
um so that's where a lot of the
challenges come from but also makes it
very interesting
um so really for this because it's sort
of these complications it's
automated logging and testing are really
key for all of these components
and that's where a lot of this lies is
just making sure everything is recorded
and so your framework is kind of as
reproducible as possible
and with that i'll say thanks very much
so thanks to my team who've
worked with me on this results and
thanks for listening everyone
um so i've got some content details here
if anyone
i would like to get in touch uh so we
post a lot
on our linkedin group and through our
medium channel as well so we have
podcasts and we also have
a lot of blogs coming out on some
insurance work at the moment i think
there's a natural language
uh model deployment blog coming out as
well soon
so yeah thanks very much everyone
thanks sam uh please do ask put any
questions in the q
a but i'll get us started so you didn't
kind of mention it
uh i did kind of mention it before you
did kind of mention it before
that you went from an experience where
you were working
you know jupiter notebook code and you
were trying to essentially deploy it
so was there any issues with um
convincing people you kind of like stop
using
notebooks or at least you can do initial
work in the notebooks but moving towards
uh you know the you know it is quite a
lot of stuff to to learn
right lots of tools do you feel like
there was some some kind of uh
pushback to to moving to to this emma
ops of working
um so i suppose yeah yeah i guess i'd
say first of all that yeah we do
use a lot of notebooks still and it is
kind of really sort of perfect for kind
of experimentation type work and
figuring out how these ideas are going
to work in the first instance
um i suppose in this case it sort of
became quite obvious
there was there was three of us working
on this team
um and it became quite obvious that we
really had to do something kind of
different because
um it was just very messy we worked so
sort of hard and fast to get
everything working um that
it was sort of well this is going to be
very messy to deal with
even running it once more with the
identical data it sort of keep your
fingers crossed
hopefully this will work um so we kind
of all
in the instance of working through that
problem i guess we all sort of convinced
ourselves um that that would be the
issue
um and then i guess since then um
because now at the moment i guess the
way gft works um
is that we're sort of producing sort of
prototypes of a new sort of um
technology but at the same time making
it production ready so it could be
deployed so
um with that kind of setup we really
have to have all this instrumentation in
place otherwise
uh sort of the results the other way are
sort of potentially sort of more
worrying
that i guess you start to get a bit
nervous that things might not work if
they're not really
sort of tied up and sort of sorted out
properly
yeah that makes sense um but it is
interesting that it
it is kind of like an adoption it is a a
change of way of
the way of doing things a bit and i
think it's um
it's important for people to change but
it is
it is tough sometimes to convince people
that this is worth
investing investing into yeah yeah for
sure we had a lot of problems or not
say we had a lot of um say discussions
around say these particular set of
technologies we've decided on so
um that was a lot of the work we were
doing say um
setting up the group at the beginning
just deciding on say
just going through a lot of these
different tools and picking which ones
made sense for us to use so
um because as i said say in terms of
collaboration you all want to be on the
same page on the same platform so
um you kind of all have to go through
and have a discussion and
find out sort of what are the pros and
cons for these different technologies
and
what would fit for our particular group
so we can all kind of
use be aligned on everything sort of
moving forwards
um i've been told there might be an
issue with the q a box if you can't
write your question in the q a box
please just put it in the chat
so nges asks at the last meeting we
heard about
feature stores do you think feature
stores are mature enough
for ml ops to use in production
uh so i think i haven't used so much
feature source i know there are
see a lot of feature stores in um some
of these production tools so the new
version of the kind of ai
tools on gcp has a feature store built
in so it has a vertex ai
um a lot of the work we've been doing i
guess we're setting up
a new project on new data sets so we
haven't used so much of a persistent
feature still because we're often
getting set up on a new data set sort of
looking into the hypothesis and then
moving to a different data set um but it
does look like there are sort of more
features and store
type tools in place but it's one that i
haven't used too much myself
we have another question in the chat do
you have a recommendation for industries
that cannot use
cloud platforms like google but
but need to run their workflows on
premise for instance for
regulatory or privacy reasons
yeah so i mean a lot of these tools are
open source
so we use a lot of these managed
services because it
reduces the sort of the management for
us but
most of these services are based on open
source tools so
airflow is an apache project
ml flow is an open source data bricks
project and great expectations again is
open source
um so a lot of these kind of different
tools and practices are all available
open source
it would just be you would have to sort
of do more of the maintenance yourself
we have another question in the qa
how long did it take you to move from a
jupiter notebook only environment to the
proper
uh ml ops um
so i guess it's quite a lot of
potentially it can be quite a lot of
work in the first
instance we've kind of layered our
approach say as we've built up
so um first of all we started just
looking at
pipeline tools and we built tools with
airflow
and then we added on ml flow and then we
added on
great expectations and we're using say
every time we add on a layer we tend to
try and automate the process so
you can kind of build up your
capabilities as you go
and this would allow you say you can
start a new project and then start
up your system and you work from say um
the point you got to before
it's kind of the same for the
infrastructure's code thing as well so
our infrastructure can get slightly more
complicated and we just build up
our capability at sort of deploying this
code
all right thank you very much i think
that's it for the questions
so i would just like to say thank you
again sam for
for this great talk and
and we'll just have a two minute break
and then we'll get started with the
lightning talks
um checher if you can share your screen
we can get started then
right um just to say for the lightning
talks
we can also have a few questions but
since the talks are five minutes it
should be
something like a minute or two of
questions if anyone has any
so i'll wait until people write
something up in the q a
right let's just take a small break and
then we'll come back
at 45.
all right so uh let's let's get started
with our first lining talk
from axel fuentes and how to ask for
help
hello everyone i'm axel fuentes some
people know me as
chacho
today i'm going to talk about
how to ask for help
well this is me when i start to call
until now sometimes
and probably might be a frustrated task
especially at the beginning
a new environment new syntax another
language
new packages looks overwhelming i think
so many times we don't get expected
output
when we run a script and that worries us
right and that's my story
if if you have had this mood once
please send me through the chat
and yeah and what happened when
when we have a programming problem
sadly we asked for help
so might be the expectation
we have to read the documentation but in
reality
the first thing we do is go to some
online community
another common aspect is is
an expectation where we have to review
similar questions
before posted one but the reality
is that we post your your your own
question immediately
then i'm not trying to say that as for
help it's bad
not at all as for help it's not the
problem
but maybe you are trying to have a quick
answer
but even if you get it probably you are
not going to understand it
then you are going to copy and paste
main problem here if you don't
understand what's your problem
so now you have two problems
yeah and
[Music]
the fact here is that you are to
online community without weapons
so i recommend you to try to understand
first your problem
until go to an online community
go line by line through your script see
what every single line does
what the function does what the package
does
and for sure you'll learn that ordering
during this process and this is very
valuable
try and try and try or
as they imagine say just do it
and if you not get it
then go for help if you want to level up
your coding skills
you will have to read code and
documentation
so the more i hear is please don't go to
the war without grips
for short here are some tips in order to
understand your doubts
first name your question then have to
resume your problem in one sentence
second give a fairly background explains
what are your goals or the problem that
you are trying to solve
and also the tools that you are just
second uh the third
and and i think this is the most crucial
step you have to
be you show a piece of your code when
you
think the problem is not all your code
if you did the above
steps right the community can know what
is
at the top and at the bottom of your
screen
i mean show that you are not looking for
someone
to solve your entire problem
and finally describe that piece of code
what is your respected output your
actual output or if exists
what is the error
yeah um community will give you the
right answer
if and only if you provide them the
right piece of the puzzle
understand your problem it's important
to communicate
your problem accurately remember every
mind is a word
in in the college a professor said
to my class learn to define your system
and and someone
sometimes said to me don't put yourself
trying to do something
because if you are pushing yourself you
are don't enjoy it
and if you are don't enjoy it you are
not learning
there is no rush all place is here all
moment is now
then be kind with yourself so happy
coding everyone
thank you very much thank you chacho
uh excel um
cool any questions really quickly
you can put in the q a or in the chat
so i'll leave it for a few seconds
i think we might be okay kate
if you can share your screen so we can
do the next lightning talk
please
i hope you can see it now
we cannot see it at the moment okay i'll
share again
yes we can i think we might be seeing
the second
second slide yeah
perfect all right so let's get started
thanks kate
thank you my name is kate taylor i
normally work on the science park at
lingamatics
where we're a data mining company today
i wanted to talk to you about python and
the semantic web
anyone with a smart device has probably
come across problems like this
you ask your smart device to turn on the
living room lights and you get told
there's no pudding room
i mean to me personally i think i'd be
disappointed by the back of a pudding
room too
but um joking apart is there some way
that we could make these smart
devices understand a little bit more
about what's going on
and link to that i mean when we're
looking at text can we find a way of
disambiguating and working out what's
actually happening the semantic web's
been around for a while
it was um the term was coined by tim
berners-lee um way back when
uh to the idea of encoding data so that
it could be processed by machines
and so we've had a go in coding in xml
and what financial and medical data is
encoded that way
we all use json rdf is another way of
trying to embed
knowledge together and build
relationships owl is used for ontologies
so there's quite a few formats out there
i worked in the university of cambridge
computer laboratory funded by mit
in the mid 2000s um we were writing a
help
compiler help system for verilog using
prologue
because there was no python yet but the
idea was that we would try to find
relevant parts of the manual or
wikipedia to display
uh and that we would mine out to mit's
new concept net
uh to see if we could help with um
misunderstandings so we were buildings i
kind of use the model to see how the
person was learning this new language if
you're interested in that you can read
our publications at the link below
concept ned is a um as it is just by the
name a network
so um concepts are in the nodes
and relationships are in the graphs so
uh it understands things like is a
has part of is used for made of
similar and that is enough to um and
hazard which is enough to make up quite
a
powerful network at the time i was using
it
um with prologue it was not particularly
large um so we couldn't make too much
use of it
especially it wasn't particularly strong
in the area of um
big science because it was done by crowd
sourcing um which meant not many people
were that much interested
a lot of our information was coming on
about real life things which again is
brilliant
but now um data's come on board in the
last few years from games with a purpose
and other linked data
that we can't come in from our and rdf
sources as well
so today is different matter and of
course today we've got other options um
to talk to the
concept net so um i decided to explore
again
using python and i use the examples in
the bottom link
on the left hand side so i was really
interested in
is the concept of relatedness of two
concepts
so here um i've used the request library
um i'm using the
python console and i'm asking how
related
is a mug and a cup so
both of them are suitable for putting
hot drinks in
and because they share a common parent
then we get a relatedness
of five uh 0.541
so this is a measure of how close they
are on the graph
and if i was to put in mug and mug i
would get a value of 1.
so okay let's go back to this this poor
smart device
um could we have used this kind of
network to help with that
so i put in living room and pudding
and i get back a value of 0.031 they're
not related at all
um if so very distantly
um probably because they're both
inanimate objects now
um obviously um a smart device has also
got to deal with speech recognition
but once the recognizing has been done
and the information's in textual form
then yes you could in theory try and
plug in this kind of thing a
disambiguation for a smart device
or for a piece of text
whilst i was here i thought i would see
if puddings are related to happiness
in my book they frequently are um
according to concept net
less so but hey um computers don't know
everything do they
as i said i work for lingamatics we're
rapidly expanding
um obviously with the coveted um
epidemic and and all the
existing medical work we do um we really
do need
some more people um a lot of our data is
in unstructured text so we're looking at
these kind of concepts
we're looking at machine learning to do
feature detection
um we take our output from our um
documents and database analysis and tap
with them into machine learning
um we do a lot of disambiguation and
sentiment analysis spelling corrections
ocr
if any of this is of tall interest to
you and please do get in touch with us
at the um
url at the bottom of the page and we'd
be pleased to hear from you
thank you very much any questions would
be welcome
okay thank you very much kate any
questions for kate
please do post them now i will wait a
few seconds
i'm i'm also disappointing there there
is no pudding room
that sounds great there is one question
uh concept looks fun what other api
endpoints would you
recommend trying out
i've used wordnet in the past which
again is another way of
helping with disambiguation um i mean i
think there are
quite a few ways the um i think our
ontologies for example often always
offer
um api end points as do um ontologies
written in another format called ansi
ansi
so i mean there's plenty around
happy to discuss that further later
yeah i guess they can come in
contact with you i can yes kate.taylor
lingomatics.com perfect um but
there doesn't seem to be any other
questions so we'll move on to our last
lightning talk which is one of our own
only one of the organizers
with his lighting talk only if you can
share your screen
please yep i'm here and i'm just
i just realized i didn't do a trial run
of the
screen sharing so probably kind of okay
now
no it's okay we can see it okay cool
all right so for a last line you talk
let's uh have ollie
yeah thank you very much so um
my lightning talk is unusual because um
it uh has not so much python
uh but it has a lot of history in it and
um
i'm going to start with a picture
many of you will remember at the the
onset of the covet crisis the
nhs uh founded a lot of
several emergency hospitals all over the
country uh this year is a picture
from wikipedia of the the uh
uh the clinic that was set up in in
london
and uh if you look very carefully in the
middle you see that it's called
the nightingale hospital so it is named
after
florence nightingale and i was just
curious what the story was behind that
person and i
i realized um this person florence
nightingale has a
very interesting life story and this has
interesting
takeaway points for data scientists
nowadays as well
so florence nightingale lived in the
19th century
and she was trained as a nurse but she
had also a very keen
interest in in statistics and in in
particular data
so obviously the term data scientist uh
didn't exist back then but uh
the the application and the analysis of
data was very
uh important to her and um
she she um traveled florence and
nightingale traveled a lot
um and um one
one of her travels coincided with the
war in
in crimea which is again in the news
nowadays
um and um in
that that was the role of the the
ottoman empire against the russian
empire but the the british
troops british troops were also involved
so florence
uh traveled to one of the field
hospitals of the british
army near uh istanbul um in turkey
and um and the the conditions were they
were horrific
um had absolutely nothing to do with
with a hospital as we know it
nowadays there was no no sanitation no
no uh sewage absolutely no basic levels
of hygiene
um no food provisions and then terrible
uh diseases like typhoid river right
uh and and the mortality was was very
very high
so uh florence nightingale set out to to
improve these these
horrible standards and introduced like
sewage and and
laundry facilities to wash sheets and
clothing of the soldiers
and and and and regular uh food supplies
as well so so lots of things that are
just pretty
common standard nowadays but were not
back then
and um so so this is all good in velvet
but as i said already florence
nightingale also had
had really this very very meticulous
attitude to to data and she wanted to
use
uh data to basically make her point
that hygiene and and
food provisions are just important to
keep
wounded soldiers alive in a hospital and
um this is one of the analysis that
uh you came up i'm sure um
many of you have seen this plot already
but maybe not looked into the details so
so those are um it's it's kind of like a
time
series that you see here so so time
runs from the right most plot
sort of like in in counterclockwise
direction you see how these
uh uh these sections are labeled with
different months so
we start at the beginning of the war and
and then the time moves
further and then the the smaller uh plot
on the left hand side is this uh second
half of the
crimean war and um the these these
sections these colored sections in
uh represent soldiers that died and the
colors represent the death causes
and um in blue is basically from
um diseases
or deaths from of soldiers from diseases
and then
uh red is uh like wounds usually runes
you know
that occurred in in uh in in battle
and and black are all other types of uh
death causes uh lumped together and you
can see the the
um for the most months sort of like the
first
part of the war the the number of uh
death that occurred from diseases just
vastly outnumbered all other
causes of death and then sort of like
between march
18 and 55 and in the next months
things things start to change and um
and uh and this is basically where
uh these sanitary changes and hygiene
changes that uh
florence nightingale uh introduced in
the hospital started to kick in so so so
the
death rates dropped very significantly
so you see the
the zoomed part uh how how the numbers
and the relation of the causes of deaths
change
so florence nightingale used this plot
basically when she was back in london
to prove her point to the british
government and to introduce these
changes uh and and they became
far more common uh in in the british
army and then also other armies and in
other hospitals all over the world
and florence nightingale became over the
years a really
highly respected figure for you know
nursing and and and standards of
hospitalization and there nowadays
um memorials and and and uh statues for
her
um in many places this one years in
london to remember the house where she
lived
um so now you might ask why is he
telling you all of uh violence why is he
telling us
all of this i i think it's a very
interesting story because
a lot of the problems that florence
nightingale had uh
might um sound very familiar to us
and of course you know nowadays we have
we have cloud computing and we have
machine learning
but sort of the underlying problems you
know existed already
back then in the 19th century so so
um when florence nightingale arrived to
this hospital it was just not known
why so many people are dying and what
the causes are nobody was literally
counting how many people
are dying every month so she had to
start and
and and collect this data
and and it was not clear what
the causes of death what the underlying
causes of this
the and sort of this idea that you could
use
graphics to tell a story and to convey
your opinion
and to to shape opinion is um
it was also relatively new and she
shaped that and another
uh funny uh sort of anecdote from her
life was
is that she actually shared for some
time a flat
with her cousin who was a professional
graphics designer and i think a lot of
the
diagrams and and plots that florence
nightingale designed
this this cousin had had had an impact
as well so
collaborations with other disciplines
were already key
back then so i found this this whole
life story was really fascinating
there's a lot more details
to it that you can read up uh in these
links
um there are also people that are trying
to reproduce uh many of
uh florence nightingales plots in python
yes the last link
is about that and finally my my uh
last slide of conclusion is you know
we always look for speakers as federico
said
so please step forward volunteer to give
a talk and help us grow the
the data science community in cambridge
and yeah you can contact us under these
email address thank you very much
thanks solei uh i thank you for your
talk uh i think that
visualization is quite famous and it's
quite important um
we we probably should host a lot more
visualization
uh talks we don't actually
i don't recall we have a lot of them so
if you anyone has a visualization talk
please please contact us
um well that's it anyone have any
questions for only if not i think then
that's the end of our meetup
and i would like to essentially thank
everyone for coming
hopefully soon we can
see each other in person in an actual
physical meetup
thank you i think there's no question so
thank you everybody and that's the end
bye thanks
thank you